champion dans la motorisation de base
fiat avec la panda continue dans cette
voie pourtant moins rentable aujourd'hui
car petite ou grosse une voiture doit
obéir en 1980 aux mêmes réglementations
de plus en plus nombreuses et coûteuses
sur la panda fiat à utiliser toutes les
possibilités pour une simplification à
l'extrême de la conception afin de
réduire les prix
moteur
reprise des excellentes bases de la 127
traction avant 903 centimètres cubes 45
chevaux pare-chocs plastique mais faux
sur les côtés seulement de la peinture
toutes les vitres plate y compris le
pare brise
quant aux tableaux de bord simple mais
bien équipé
la panda c'est un monument d'astuces au
niveau de l'aménagement des sièges
rustique mais suffisant et une banquette
arrière en toile tendue entre deux tubes
démontable
[Musique]
première possibilité berline 4 places
avec malle classique accessible par un
hayon deuxième version sièges rabattus
banque est déplié deux couchettes
[Musique]
troisième version la banquette arrière
devient un hamac quatrième version
banquette replier ou démonter c'est un
vaste break plus d'un mètre cube de
volume de charge en fait un utilitaire
vraiment polyvalent où l'on entre eux
mêmes une échelle de 2 mètres 50
[Musique]
intelligente par excellence la panda
c'est la voiture pour les jeunes de tout
âge urbaine avant tout 3 mai 38 de long
1 m 46 dos large
elle se faufile aisément 45 chevaux pour
680 kg lui confère de bonnes
accélérations et l'absence d'assistance
de frein n'est guère gênante
par contre sur la route c'est moins
brillant pour se situer en quatre
chevaux fiscaux et garantir de faible
consommation
la boîte tire un peu long mais le gros
défaut c'est le confort vraiment
épouvantable pour les passagers arrière
fiat pays là le tribut d'une conception
technique un peu trop simpliste
quant au freinage il ne brille guère par
la stabilité jamais une voiture n'avait
été aussi bien conçu au niveau de
l'utilisation rationnelle de l'espace
intérieur
mais le minimum automobile ce doit être
aussi un minimum de qualités routières
de finition et de confort car nous
sommes aujourd'hui en 1981 et la panda
coûte 23 1900 francs médiocre et génial
outils et gadgets la panda des chaînes
des avis contradictoires le pire et le
meilleur
[Musique]